maybe we're looking at a net positive in
the lung in a long term I mean I hope we
don't we don't end up with you know
escalation of force we're gonna get
death and stuff but if kovat and these
riots result in people just fleeing
cities maybe it's a good thing get them
out into the world get them more
responsible you know what man it's it's
it's you it's a utopian world view but
how great would it be if people had mini
farms I love that you have you grow your
own food in the back mm-hmm meat and
stuff and other other products they have
to be done in bigger scale you go to
store it to buy but for the most part
you've got veggies and fruits and maybe
even your own chickens yeah of course
you know but then I guess the challenge
is the Roosters all over the all over
the community screaming in there you get
used to him I like roosters they were a
little annoying
no the goat was annoying the goat was
especially for me because I was on that
side of the house where the goat was
like right there I named him Kurt Kurt
oh those wondering we really yeah we
lived in Miami for a while and we we
were outside yeah we were we were
basically two farms away from the
Everglade line yeah like you go to farms
over and that was the Everglades so we
were we were out in the boonies but you
know everybody had Brewster's all around
us he'd wake up in the morning there
does you'd hear them all of the way and
they scream at night too don't they but
there was one thing that was pretty
consistent Kurt this is a message for
Kurt the goats if I wasn't vegan now
you're cool no no you know what I know
why you was upset that the they've
separated him from his lover from his
lady go from his lady go so I mean I
feel for you Kurt I feel for you yes so
so we had a waiter rooster that Adam
named Jay Noren oh man Lauren
I named him Nora is it magic there's a
Magic the Gathering called card called
Noren lowary yep and the theme of the
card is he's terrified and useless so we
had this rooster the way at the sign of
anything did nothing to protect the
chickens no and the cat kept getting in
and then would just flee the yard and go
into the other yard where the other
roses would beat the crap out of them
yeah it's true that damn rooster man we
thought he was like we thought he was a
mentally mentally deficient mentally
deficient
yeah that poor rooster nor in the way we
still alive though we end up you
was the the chickens names the Ghana and
I don't know you named him Nora no no
that was the bunny and I remember the
other two Ghana was that was one of
these one of them though yeah all magic
really anyway anyway I think Jack I
think you know I think about people who
live in the cities and it always sounded
insane like vice for instance mm-hmm was
notorious for underpaying people like
when I started working there in in it
was this was 2011 2013 2013 okay there
were people there making 27k a year and
living in Williamsburg I'm spending you
know I'm spending all of it on rent yes
seriously and I and I remember you know
there was one person who literally
rented the apartment right next to the
vice building like literally walk up the
door and you walk in and whoa right near
the water there no no other other
direction okay okay but literally the
building next device is building and I'm
like this has got to be like for this
room fifteen hundred bucks
yeah I'm like how much do you make you
like thirty some I'm like are you are
you spending like 70% of your take-home
income on rent just to live here
yeah what's going on yeah they dumpster
dive now the rich vice people were like
I have the penthouse down the street now
I'm right yeah but you make hundreds of
thousands of dollars yeah yeah these
people were so desperate to live there
mm-hmm that they had no savings and I
tell you what man cuz I told a story
before about you know people saying like
I want to do what you do man I want to
travel around covering news yeah and I'd
be like okay stop spending fifteen
hundred bucks a month on rent yeah go go
crashing your buddy's couch work up on
our bucks and you at the funniest thing
is well this is hilarious I'm talking to
some like young intern who's spending a
thousand bucks a month and they're like
I want to do what you do and I say okay
here's my advice
all that mone again you got save it all
right so you guys save so you got to
find some friends you got to live you
got a sacrifice and they're like uh-huh
and you lost me no no no way it's better
and they're like but I like my apartment
right and I'm like bro you're asking me
for advice while I sleep on my friend's
couch right now
I was III had a friend in Williamsburg I
paid him you know like three and seven
bucks to sleep on his couch in his
living room you know why I made more
money than they did advice yeah but I
put it all in the bank yeah and I'm like
I don't need better
man I need to get the job done and I
need to save every penny cuz you never
know you never know when that storms
coming and you never know when
opportunity comes and knockin and I'll
tell you this one day you'll be sitting
there and it's like you know you know
reminds me of actually using that
commercial for the peanut butter or for
milk where the guy it's his old
commercial and he puts all the peanut
butter on the bread and then he bites it
and then the phone rings and it's the
radio station saying who killed
Alexander Hamilton and that famous duel
and he's in a room where he's surrounded
by all of this Aaron Burr memorabilia
and he's got peanut butter in his mouth
and he goes rolling Bull and they're
like I'm sorry sir we can't hear you
better luck next time and then he's like
he's like pour the milk so I can answer
it but there's no milk left that lad
never seen that but okay so here's the
point here's the point but you painted a
wonderful and wonderful picture thank
you
that milk if he had just had the milk
the opportunity came a-knockin he didn't
I mean wouldn't water work the table
he's got a thing a milk and he's
mouthful peanut butter and he tries to
port nothing comes out he was horrible
he's like in the room and everything's
right it's funny but he's got a painting
of it and there's like the bullet in a
glass case obviously the thing this is
his house it was a cotton mill
commercial these people sacrifice all
the wrong things yeah and then we'll
finally one day opportunity comes to
their door and says would you like to
fly with me to Ferguson there's a huge
story I need your help or on our own
though and they go I have no money maybe
if you didn't spend it on the booze from
that party last night and on his
expensive apartment when I came asking
for your help
you were there to come or not not so
much that but like so much of the trips
that I had done before I start working
provides I paid for everything on my own
I saved everything I could
when I went out get donations or
whatever and that was the opportunity so
so so long story short we'll wrap her up
yeah wrap it back up to the original
point yeah cities are too expensive
they're too expensive Haitian not only
that are they too expensive I think the
most pressing thing is you you're paying
to live you're paying someone else to
live yes that's what it is
well it's in and if you stay there and
you live
there and your family lives there it's
like your I don't care what race you are
it it's if you live in a city you're
paying someone else and your group
raising a family and paying another
person to raise a family you're not able
to give them that house right you talked
about it it's about generational wealth
can't exist in a city unless you promote
people no unless you become a building
owner or and/or have a building passed
to you you know but that it's hard to to
get up like that if you're stuck in in
city paying someone else yep so moving
out out of the we're the pioneers at
let's get rid of the cities yeah you
know I was well there was a movie
recommendation on Hulu called almost
heroes okay it's awful it's Chris Farley
movie and Matthew Perry okay and I've
never seen it before never seen but
apparently it's like during Lewis and
Clark I like Chris Chris Farley I didn't
what I do was not I turned it off really
yeah it was 90s movie or something
anyway the point was it was about
Matthew Perry this you know East Coast
colonial era dude and he was like I'm
going to chart a route to the Pacific
and I'm sitting there thinking about it
and like man do we have anybody who does
that like most people just want the easy
way out
yeah everything was done for you but
that's how it's been you know what's
messed up man you can't we're in that
place that you just pay to go get food
you walk to the store you pay for a
burger you walk to any store and you pay
to get whatever you need in a city it's
all available to you and not just that
but you're making all the other people
money and a lot of these people in New
York the money is coming from them
writing articles about Brad Pitt's jump
right so they're like 17 times Brad
Pitt's junk was cut on camera and it's
like you're getting paid 50 grand a year
to do that so they value nothing right
the purpose I just
eyeballs attention economy man yeah so
you know I thought about in the past
like what drove someone to want to leave
European you know countries to spend
months and about where you you might die
and a lot of people didn't make it
across the ocean that's true and then
when you finally did you landed on a
rock and they're like well there's all
the nothing it's all you just like
jumped out screaming and ran across the
continent that's nothing so like what
man
you imagine that you're like you got off
the boat with your family you're just
you know first of all the boats didn't
come to shore you come you get you they
go to the little boats right and they
row you to shore and then you're yeah
then you climb out onto the sand and
you're like this is it and your family's
like this is it like this is where you
brought us yep start cutting down that
tree yeah I'm sure there's something I'm
missing about it but there weren't like
the you know I'm sure once the first few
pioneers came the first thing they did
was like start building you know a dock
and building temporary housing and
shelters and things like that and then
companies were involved I'm sure I don't
know a lot about it but I'm willing to
bet like the first that happened wasn't
families coming it was like workers and
crews thinking about fur traders was
right yeah
couldn't they send stuff back I'm
thinking about what we would do for like
terraforming Mars like we're not gonna
send a bunch of families with kids to go
and just live on Mars no isn't
scientists and engineers but no but at
the same time they are trying to send
family not not with kids though but I
mean the two astronauts that just flew
they're married two astronauts that also
flew and have both education and the
space station so I mean technically yes
they want families to go out there so
that it's less traumatic you know yeah
yeah it's a good point so maybe with
specialized families the people hold
them yeah certain age but but regardless
of any of that
could you imagine just someone being
like get in this plane we're gonna drop
you off in the middle of the woods and
then it's all you
isn't that basically of all these shows
that are you know reality get dropped oh
man how long can you have you seen the
rigid and afraid yeah I can't think of
any others have you seen the viral
offensive one where they put all the men
on one island and all the woman on the
other Island no yeah yeah yeah yeah and
so all the women okay so so man it is
they had to have done some purpose oh
man but some people think it wasn't on
purpose like that's just what happens
when women are left alone uh-huh all
right so the women get lost okay they
struggle they cry they break down and
they beg to leave they start fighting
with each other they start gossiping the
man mm-hmm have clean water shelter
together banded together fire
then the women started demanding they
get access to you know something men had
built and stuff like that and you know
it's a smile
hold on you obviously have an opinion
okay I worked in nursing and I loved
most of my co-workers but they did like
to gossip and gossiping was a serious
problem and they talk about nurses
eating their young I'm like what uh yes
nurses are just women in general
nurses specifically the field of Nursing
ninety-eight percent female nurses eat
their young you get a new nurse on the
floor you're in the ICU she gets no help
who cares if her patient dies wow this
really bothers that's rough okay this
really bothers me because it's not about
showing this new nurse what's what it's
about taking care of the patient okay so
there's proof that's not all well but
I'm also saying that's Lydia's proof
that not all women are like that so yeah
yeah yeah it's funny I once saw I once
read a story about chickens Oh
did you know that there there's you know
the super chicken is I know I'm very
interested so they just like shoot out
eggs so chickens have a pecking order
yes okay and there's like one chicken
dominates and tells all the other
chickens like I make my super chicken no
other it's the females that's the voice
that some no no it's more like sassier
than that I'm in charge I'm the super
chicken you listen to me that's that
sounds like a Karen chicken exactly
exactly so I read the story no no you
were saying that they actually had
hierarchy and were actually the ones in
charge that's not a Karen super chickens
okay they are the managers yeah oh yeah
anyway but I read the story and and this
is gonna be proof about what she was
saying because you know chickens and
they so they they they took a bunch of
different groups of chickens okay
and they took each of the super chicken
from each you know like chicken group
yeah and they tried they wanted to see
what would happen if they took all of
the dominating hens yeah and put them
together and you know what they did when
they took all of the super they took you
know it so it's like twelve chickens per
group or whatever and they took the
dominant one from each group and then
put them all in one group and you know
what happened did they kill each other
they pecked each other
death called it murder just do just
corpses everywhere what was there like
one just with one you know one leg up on
the rest like the well I'm the winner
legend has it that as this as the the
queen chicken as the scientists and
researchers were walking away
they faintly heard but that's uh that's
that I actually read that story that
they they wanted to experiment to see
what happen to a pecking order if I took
all of the super chickens putting
together and they just killed each other
Wow
so I'm kidding about that being evidence
you know oh and we know what we have
proof that chickens eat their young
because they straight-up ate their own
eggs well that's a problem actually I
was reading about Kelo really no it's
it's it's it's a habit because chickens
are really dumb chicken like totally
different but no yeah I was reading like
they can get a taste for a guinea and
it's tense too late and they just keep
wrecking their eggs because they're
really dumb yeah yeah chickens are not
smart you know and then eat grass - I
like chickens I look forward I look
forward to getting some farm animals in
but mandating the traders in the yard
they do yeah yeah like they start
stripping the lawn over time just
spreading out everything was getting
purged and I'm like the grass doesn't
grow fast enough for these critters man
I mean heaven honey we had a lotta grass
though on that property oh yeah it was
acreage is huge it several acres five
five plus or something like that not the
biggest but but big enough but how did
we end up talking about okay you know
what
I don't complain we're having a good
time I don't question these things I'm
okay with a don't want someone to catch
at says Tim is high AF no yeah you know
what that's that's funny but if someone
says that almost every day in a single
episode I see it I'm like well we're the
getting that I remember out like a most
clean-cut person I know ya know you
don't drink you don't do anything you
don't even like taking allergy medicine
yeah when I staying with my friends in
the south side of Chicago like
conveniently in these same places you
know not too far we talk about crazy
stuff quantum physics time dilation all
this weird stuff and then they'd always
be like dude are you stoned
I'd be like no
no this stuff is just awesome are you
gonna tell me that you're only
interested in science in the universe
when you're on like smokin BOTS
shouldn't you always be interested yes
yes the answer is yeah I think I very
much am right interested in science I
felt like I needed to finish the
sentence there so what someone in the
chat said use chicken at chickens has
tillers yeah works
yeah awesome
you know the earthworms I need those
things oh really for what well you just
don't let him get into the garden keep
the garden looper we were talking about
this because we were talking about the
island with women and you mentioned it
all back hold on before we move on we
have a lot of earthworms in our backyard
yes we have meant just in case i realize
them they're wonderful Oh
sidenote yeah okay we can maybe and we
can continue well I think we we updated
everyone on our status I think we've
just about we did it yeah I'm having a
great time thanks for checking out this
clip from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do
the show live Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. if you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or check us out on
iTunes and Spotify and we will soon have
this podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you